Madame Elisabeth Doisneau rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des finances mes
chers collègues nous nous apprêtons à
examiner premier projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de la
législature ces conditions d'examen par
l'Assemblée nationale ont été
particulières vous n'allez pas me
contredire les députés ont tout d'abord
rejeté les premières et deuxième partie
du texte relative au compte du dernier
exercice clos et à la rectification des
prévisions de recettes et aux objectifs
de dépenses de l'année en cours 2022 par
la suite le gouvernement a engagé à deux
reprises sa responsabilité en
application de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution une première fois sur la
troisième partie du texte relative aux
recettes de l'année à venir avant même
d'avoir commencé l'examen de cette
partie
une seconde fois sur la quatrième partie
relative aux dépenses de l'année et à
venir sur l'ensemble du PLFSS après
avoir examiné quelques articles
concernant pour l'essentiel la branche
autonomie
il en résulte que le PLFSS pour 2023
nous arrive tronqués vider de ces deux
premières parties ce qui est assez
inédit que le gouvernement n'a pas pu
rétablir quand il a engagé sa
responsabilité sur les parties suivantes
surtout le débat parlementaire lui-même
a jusqu'à présent été tronqué au vu des
enjeux financiers et politiques
particulièrement important des projets
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale nous avons donc la
responsabilité de faire vivre au Sénat
des débats complets sur le plfs pour
2023 soyez sûr mesdames messieurs des
ministres que ces débats seront à
l'image du Sénat c'est à dire sérieux et
respectueux mais aussi exigeant et
parfois en contradiction avec votre
approche
au contenu de ce projet de financement
de la sécurité sociale comme l'on dit
les ministres les contes de la sécurité
sociale s'améliorent depuis le trou
d'air historique de l'année 2020 pic de
la crise sanitaire économique et sociale
provoquée par l'épidémie de covid-19
de ce point de vue le gouvernement
considère que l'année à venir 2023
devrait de nouveau marquer une
progression avec un déficit réduit à 7,2
milliards d'euros cela reste
significatif bien sûr pour des comptes
censés être équilibrés mais nous sommes
loin des quelques 39,8 milliards d'euros
de 2020 record historique de déficits
des comptes sociaux nous en acceptons
l'augure cependant notre commission a
exprimer son inquiétude face aux
chiffres que vous nous présentez
inquiétude quant à la crédibilité des
comptes pour 2023 tout d'abord le
tableau d'équilibre repose sur des
hypothèses que le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques qualifie d'optimiste
d'une part pour ce qui concerne les
recettes le gouvernement prévoit une
croissance du PIB de 1% et une nouvelle
progression de la masse salariale à 5%.
d'autre part pour ce qui concerne les
dépenses le gouvernement prévoit une
quasi disparition des dépenses liées au
covid 19 l'approvision correspondant à
seulement 1 milliard d'euros ça nous
semble un peu faible ce qui devra là
aussi être vérifié et nous comptons nous
donner
les moyens de le faire
et nous comptons vous donner les moyens
de le faire
vous ne comptez d'ailleurs que sur cette
vision optimiste de la conjoncture
économique et sanitaire pour tenir les
comptes et pas sur les mesures que vous
prendrez à cet égard il est significatif
que le solde que nous transmet
l'Assemblée nationale est égale au sol
de tendancières c'est-à-dire au solde
que l'on constaterait sans prendre
aucune mesure en définitive au niveau de
ce PLFSS notre inquiétude aussi pour
l'avenir en effet si l'on se penche au
delà de 2023 au travers de ce que
propose l'annexe B qui est Quadriennale
de ce PLFSS on peut observer que le
déficit relativement modeste espéré pour
2023 ne devrait être qu'une étape sur le
chemin du retour à l'équilibre mais bien
plus tôt une simple embellie avant un
nouveau creusement des déficits selon
vos propres prévisions la situation des
contes de la sécurité sociale devrait se
dégrader dès 2024 un niveau de
8,8 milliards d'euros mais surtout
atteindre un niveau plus tard plus
inquiétant autour de 12 milliards
d'euros de déficits par an 2020 en 2025
et 2026
or tout ce scénario repose là aussi sur
des hypothèses de croissance optimistes
et des perspectives de maîtrise des
dépenses notamment sur l'ONDAM dont nous
ne savons rien ainsi l'annexe B qui a
aussi pour vocation de donner une
visibilité et une stratégie pour
l'avenir ne donne aucun détail sur les
moyens que le gouvernement envisage de
se donner pour maîtriser les comptes par
exemple il est tout juste précisé que le
solde de la branche vieillesse
bénéficierait de l'objectif d'élévation
progressive de l'âge effectif de départ
sur le quinquennat le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques déplore lui aussi que
vos prévisions supposent des effets
importants et immédiats de réforme dont
ni les modalités ni les impacts ni le
calendrier ne sont documentés
en somme cette trajectoire qui devrait
se dégrader dès 2024 reste hélas une
version optimiste de l'avenir des
comptes sociaux il est donc à craindre
que les déficits continuent de
s'accumuler et que de nouveaux
transferts à la Cadès doivent être
envisagés à l'avenir
dans cette situation la commission des
affaires sociales adopter une approche
responsable de ce PLFSS pour la résumer
en quelques mots la Commission proposera
tout d'abord de rétablir les parties de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale qui doivent exister quitte à les
corriger comme en première partie de
marquer notre refus de la vision que le
Gouvernement présente de l'avenir de la
sécurité sociale à l'annexe B à la
sincérité douteuse et à la dimension
stratégique absente de poser nous même
déjà longs de véritables mesures
d'équilibre en particulier sur les
retraites mais aussi en proposant
quelques recettes supplémentaires
et de renforcer enfin le contrôle du
Parlement notamment dans le cas où les
hypothèses optimistes du gouvernement ne
se vérifierait pas par exemple en cas de
dépassement significatif de l'ONDAM et
des dépenses d'urgence vous l'aurez
compris mesdames messieurs les ministres
nous serons tout au long de ce débat que
nous espérons riches des interlocuteurs
à la fois exigeant mes constructifs et
quelquefois si nécessaire si nécessaire
des contradicteurs je vous remercie de
votre attention
merci Madame la rapporteur général la
parole est maintenant madame